I'm a rocket on a school bus one day and
the man didn't even take us to school he
just drove us around and I swear to God
and then just drove us back home
eventually he didn't say anything either
probably drunk and went at a certain
point you ask young young monkey wait
black slaves either white slave why
pygmies everyone up in slavery nice
techno races but you're so lonely why
yeah yeah it's been lonesome man won't
try to stop a masturbation you know it's
what do you think about when you
masturbate mm-hmm I think about honestly
now at this point I Philip I think a
little bit about some kind of sexual
ideas you know but then I think about
how bad I'm gonna feel after I'm done
masturbating really why do you feel bad
he's faster bait into light shame shame
for you are you a porno guy looks like
redtube or whatever the [ __ ] you say
I've been out there man I've been in the
it's nasty out there
it's nasty dude I was just talking about
this on my podcast it's nasty some of
these videos and people doing all these
bud activities and everything and you
know the thing you are like you just
gotta it's constantly escalating like
everyone's trying to one-up each other
in the porn and I don't want to be in it
they are aren't they
it's just too much sure are I don't need
seven guys know what happened just one
on one it's on why does it have to be a
gangbang everything yeah yeah and it's
so rough whack Amole - if he sees all
those gang bangs maybe they get stuck
it's like urban whack-a-mole in Andrew
Santino has the best he talks about how
a lot of black gentlemen always have
their sneakers on during pornography
[Laughter]
grip use did a really rail at home rip
and probably its foot is rampant and
also I don't know the [ __ ] minute on
this carpet he goes back to
indoor/outdoor like those are kind of
outdoor shoes and they have one indoors
full circle with Theo von you call your
podcast full circle I've never put full
circle what's the podcast name this past
weekend it's just it was a man we had so
much fun in the city man we went to a
baseball game
and what else did we do we just Oh harm
are we walking around just hanging out
you know drinking you know how on a
cloud you know or whatever you know
people what use this this is 2002 so
just walking around and uh so there's
some people hanging out an alley that
are kind of dancing and partying a
little bit so we go over there and we
think it's like a family it's like a
birthday cake and stuff so we're singing
you know cumpleanos everybody's having a
nice time we think oh we're you know
we're in a different country we're
celebrating some guy's birthday then one
of the dudes that the birthday starts
eating this lady yell [ __ ] just like
this isn't like oh these are these are
escorts like we didn't know we thought
it was like a family and next thing
we're all dancing with these [ __ ]
ladies and said we think it's like a
grandmother like a [ __ ] birthday
party guys goes down where the ladies
waste a little low and [ __ ] starts
eating her [ __ ] right they're like what
welcome to Cuba yeah I was talking again
I went to a party and there was boats
and next you know there was a girl
[ __ ] a guy on the board I didn't know
what to do get in there somebody get
that dick suck at least go put a finger
in there at least cheer for you know my
body we got some calls and stuff that
came in Joe you mind if we jump to a
couple of them yeah I thought about it
something updated a little bit here and
there within the industry but yeah well
I'll tell you this I mean so yesterday I
go to these adult meetings sometimes for
adults and uh what do you mean just like
adult means where people get together
spend time together like a a mmm know if
it's a a really buddy CIA bro in their
back you know he's always very like he's
dating these adult meetings he's like
you talk about a a I don't drink so I'll
say that so anyways a girl right I met
this sweet gal that I'd see I seen her
for a couple weeks really been longing
for probably in my brain right long so I
get her name I get her a get her number
yesterday right well then some straight
up skis some girl just throwing that
butt around on snapchat
right send meanest says I don't have
your number right so I give her my
number on snapchat alone at home and the
evening I'm lonesome I give this girl my
number you don't have any food and there
I have a little bit of a London broil
meat okay and I uh
yeah and just me and we're eating just
me your brain gets real limbic you know
you drop into primal times you know
limbic just that London broil - that
ain't the fancy stuff it's not real it's
a tougher end of its wrathful it's a
scrapper it's the hip but what happened
was so then the snapchat girl text I
when I got the girl's number that I
really think like might have been the
one oh yeah I got her number and I just
put my name in and I texted her my name
right in front of right that way boom
there's nothing creepy about that
nothing creepy unnatural normal I was a
gentleman in the conversation
everything was good I'll see you later
young she'll you know and then though
later so the snapchat girl text me
I thought she texted me it wasn't it was
the girl that I liked a few hours later
wrote I'm gonna put you inside here I'll
read this is the thirsty snapchat girl
this ain't this is not real life no but
the thirsty snapchat girl texted me
thought it was the one that he likes
right well this is uh this is the girl
who are liked texting me back
I thought the thirsty snapchat girl was
texting me ah this is already already
back she wrote cool you are going in my
rolodex right that's what she wrote so I
thought it's a snapchat girl she'd ask
me for my number I said I want to go in
more than that creepin yeah turning
patch and I'll tell you what it is man
I'm alone by myself at night and I'm
just rock-hard got there that's a bet to
go not rock-hard soft and cutting and
just agitate it lonely wait so now that
worst thing you can head London bro I
did have a yogurt too but I was saving
that for later that was gonna be like my
nighttime at [ __ ]
look at me your nighttime cab adventure
he said so what happened what she
responds he wrote do tell
go on oh so now I think it's definitely
now I have no song now in my head no I
have no doubt it's a snapchat girl
don't think it's a snapchat yeah I have
not brought to the realization that this
is the girl that I although I she's into
it she's game
maybe that's a game was baby but who
tell go I go I want to being more than
that maybe she's thinking oh yeah I'm
seeing a nice dinner maybe a steak in it
maybe a kiss not a dick side yeah maybe
I want to peel that rump apart too much
too much yeah I want to eat so anyway as
I'm picking a little bit of London brawl
out of my mouth
dude and feeling probably with meat in
your mouth you feel more carnivorous and
also more you know I got this
yes tribal tribal yeah tribal dude how
to pet try on your primal primal primal
probably five there you go primal she
goes do tell go on I said inside of your
body right cuz I want to go in more than
that I feel like you're better than that
the can oh I do you could have been a
little more descriptive oh this isn't me
doing this this is the dark arts that
are inside of me coming out and that
doesn't mean a black man at a theater
that means the other side of it where
you're a bode design yeah just just me
feeling lonesome and even our samurai
might be dating pretty serious cuz I'm
liking this whole connection are similar
that you she's European pretty opium
yeah addis ababa I stopped at ID
survival one time yeah
nice people there had some good uh
flatbread let me finish this up so then
I said I want to go in more than that so
she goes do tell go on I said inside of
your body
then wherever you want me that's what I
creep in with it this line right she
goes wow that's how you roll huh wasting
no time so at this point I'm like why
would the snapchat girl say that you
know she just showing me like pictures
of her bud and like yeah it was a dirty
bedroom yeah and then I'm like oh my god
I'm so sorry I just realized who this
was
I don't even know what to say and that's
when we had a conversation about it
well that's could you explain the
situation I try but here's the
explanation so here's the thing I think
stop I thought you were this raging
[ __ ] who's gonna come over here this
London broil and I was gonna [ __ ] you
yeah but right turns out you actually
really nice and I probably this is the
rear
yeah I like you and I'm gonna put on an
act and I would have taken you out to
dinner and kind of bought you drinks and
who knows what could have led to I don't
know what those that over you check any
Native Americans car you always find Jin
and femurs or something you know they
love they keep the dead with him a lot
of times almost noctus unfortunately
almost knock this young lady up that was
from South Dakota and she lived in a
reservation yeah and she like threatened
to have the baby how old were you 37
this year it was this year and she
wouldn't even be cool she wouldn't she's
threatened to have the baby dude I just
met her at a motel she threatened to
have a baby man and so that's yeah and
then I met her personal in a motel only
hours later and I like that huh yeah oh
geez and it was definitely not a
recommend that kind of stuff I don't man
making love to people off a snapchat yes
this South Dakota dude this was in
Knossos in different city she was out of
she was you know out of there whatever
how'd you talk she came out she just
said immediately she's like if I have
this baby I'm like what she's like yeah
I'm having it like Jesus Chris were you
like well part I had a ton of things I
had I'm think about what I had asked
didn't I with your mom being so tough
was it like did was it tough to feel
like affection from her because
sometimes like my mom is a hard worker
right my mom delivered you know she's a
delivery woman you know she delivered
newspapers when I was a kid she delivers
magazines now she's always had a [ __ ]
van you know now she got my her husband
he's as Alzheimer's don't even know he's
in the van he's with her every day
you're [ __ ] bouncing around the
[ __ ] fantasy she had to get a [ __ ]
ii seatbelt install for who cuz he
[ __ ] what kind of sleaze gettin
little he was slip out of her house
she's got him just basically in a
[ __ ] straitjacket just bouncing
around there's no clue where he is how
its deliver if I can news on wheels
every day you know
I think he's about 90 you know mom still
does it dude
and here's the worst part brush she got
a good deal on this van right my mom
likes a good deal and she got a good
deal on Sven has no wit not other side
or back window so her [ __ ] GPS is the
Lord Russa see just like a bouncing
thing yeah I kind of realized how big of
a deal it wasn't mean it was just kind
of fun you got to compete and and I'd
always been like I think a bit afraid to
play like football in high school
because uh like if I got hurt like we
didn't have no money so it was like if
you got hurt you know you were just
gonna be that guy who's [ __ ] shirt
didn't fit right for the rest of his
life you know like if you broke your
[ __ ] clavicle or whatever to be
awkward yeah you risk him that dude with
Obamacare you didn't have a health
insurer no no we just had each a you
know we just had insight from the
neighbors you know that was our
Obamacare you know science looks broken
yeah I tie it down you know yeah I
damned people tying their legs to their
arm and [ __ ] I remember they made one
kid a [ __ ] cast out of cement one
time they [ __ ] put his leg in two uh
yeah yeah and then they had to break it
with a hammer at some point of some type
of in it broke his leg in three places
when they broke the [ __ ] cement
because they said you grew up you grew
up with very little money yeah a little
money man a lot of a lot of religion
around little money is the show about
him and his life back home all those
characters you doing your standup mm-hmm
that's the show like that boy Girt yeah
you going home right and you reuniting
with you all your all fucked-up friends
mm-hmm I'm just dealing something with
just all those stories there's just
heavenly
dude we had his kid in our in my
neighborhood named Robert and he was
like he thought he was twins that never
got separated right and so yeah when he
would talk he would say something and
then under his breath you would say it
again oh it never ended yeah and if all
this scared the [ __ ] out of everybody
bro and he could not stop doing it he
kept like an echo yeah Wow and you'd ask
him what I did and he said he was -
there was twins inside of him and one of
them never got it that's so funny
I cheated on
yeah it was the weirdest thing because I
would never do it before I want to stay
but it would be in my pocket burning a
hole yeah and I would go right from the
original room people be hey great say
yeah good right I would go right to the
bathroom me tooth and do to Banach then
I let it be all okay yeah if I'd love
the spot I wouldn't do it yeah I would
do it I would have that Coke that Coke
had me in my pocket at eight o'clock I
would fall apart at the seams
yeah put in my little drug pocket yeah
and it would stay there
unbothered a little baggy waterproof in
case the [ __ ] rain came guess the
floods came got biblical don't break out
of still in case Louisiana all over
again I'm gonna tie a float away with
[ __ ] up New York up dude how great
with every year on the news they're like
showing you yours down there doing coke
in the helicopter like how many videos
are there of the news during a Katrine
over there's a bunch of brothers just
blow in a [ __ ] blunt if I couldn't
put it on and just yell it up you can't
stop me who the [ __ ] will even have a
boy that was terrible it's gonna happen
again
yeah nice cuz like look at it I'm still
like okay now I mean you're beautiful
man you're a good man
you seem like a really good guy and I'm
happy that you find a lady that yeah
that's when we're seeing you guys laugh
and just like being like goofy and just
seemed like I was like man these two
kids or hopefully don't have a child you
know cuz this child's gonna be mentally
handicapped but I also remember cuz
where I'm from if you see two mentals
hug and you call the cops on them and
that was a rule when I was young and
that's true dude that's true if you see
two middles hugging you call the cops
immediately because once two middles
don't make a non minute you know rarely
do they and it's a risk and it's a it's
a high risk low reward that's what they
call that psychology in psychology but
yeah man you know I'm happy to be or not
yeah man and we'll hopefully next time
we'll get to know each other a little
bit better yeah my tits are out yeah you
feel the beat I remember getting off the
plane in Miami next morning my pants
were [ __ ] wet and the waitress the
stewardess was just walking the halls
look at me and give me a water you know
how [ __ ] up I was dude my buddy and
his brother used to get so [ __ ] up on
coke in Miami then they'd go to the
hotel room put on diapers bra cuz they
kept [ __ ] themselves and just go
back down to the [ __ ] dance floor
just partying with diapers full of [ __ ]
brothers dancing and they could dance
bro I mean these boys could [ __ ] dang
it once again smells like [ __ ] but I
think they stopped moving that [ __ ]
Bryce who get caught up with bats what
it's like to be I think they were
Latinos for sure to get coked up with a
dude that used to put a string on his
wrist mm-hmm and the string would go to
the doorknob so if he tried to open the
door knob his string Bryce get high with
some crazy people yeah I used to get
high with his brother who was bald and
his brother would be talking to him like
we'd be doing coke like yeah yeah and
also they go like watch me go
he smack himself because he kept
thinking flies with his head he would
smack himself 80 [ __ ] times a night
tan and we would laugh at every [ __ ]
time and map he'd smack himself he go
bro he used to put balloons he lived on
the 34th floor I had another friend Kurt
he's led now rest in peace good good
dude he used to get so paranoid that he
would put a little parachutes on his
cocaine so the cop came he would throw
it out the window and a little
parachutes to fly me that's the [ __ ]
that was the eighties you know like God
ladies is good bro craziness how that
[ __ ] just took over you never see your
plasma let me think about what happened
to me one time
oh I remember one time I got stuck in a
tunnel my car broke down in a tunnel in
Pittsburgh and I had to defecate
extremely and that's French actually for
[ __ ] yeah yeah and I did defecate and so
I got my back seat of my car and the
only like I didn't have any choice this
was like you knows like something gotten
into my
like a pink I got into my stomach well
you know and all the [ __ ] in my body was
coming out of my body yeah it was I in
your stomach yeah it was like hey we
need all this [ __ ] out of here
I didn't you buy this once in my stomach
you yeah yeah and I got diarrhea from
that too yeah yeah yeah I know how it
got down there and I didn't defecate
into a frisbee out of upside-down
frisbees oh I have a real yeah so I'm in
this tunnel there were cars whizzing by
here's the crazy thing
yeah extremely hard to poop when cars
are going by 50 60 70 miles an hour and
furious - yeah furious like it also
white people like it was Pittsburgh so
it's furious white people drive by I can
if other people are some certain
ethnicities I can [ __ ] easier when
they're driving by honestly you know
like if a couple of brothers are rolling
by blastings and [ __ ] good music I
can [ __ ] blow ass all day into a
fridge it's no problem part of it you
know everything is everybody's you know
everybody seems like this more laid-back
yeah yeah but angry white dudes you know
rolling by you know 6 7
what do you would probably call somebody
too long oh they weren't calling anybody
I mean the only free finger they had
they were waving it out the window
to dial the phone so you [ __ ] on a
frisbee kind of [ __ ] in the opened
another yeah at the top part at the
bottom part a frisbee is basically a cup
basically the size Oh play it's a play
plate well ladies is a cup are you a
place is a wide wide wide are you pulled
over I pulled it yet I'll pulled over
the car think honestly we're on again
yes oh it's dark [ __ ] in a tunnel you
ladies ok yes should be familiar with
tunnels dude why huh
because of yeah because they even do
that [ __ ] again right now man why you
no dude you're doing that nom [ __ ] again
ahh bra
what nom one you thought that I was
digging tunnels at the Ho Chi Minh Trail
no I'm the fruit juice the pomegranate
fruit juice that's always no bro I don't
believe in Vietnam I don't believe in
how they never found the boats dude all
right it's just like slavery they never
found the bones
what do you mean Turtles overall so
anyway I'm in a tunnel I'm in a tunnel
there's only two lanes going each way
there's no there's nowhere to get out on
a tunnel like in a tunnel you know cars
are whizzing by yeah and so I had to get
in the backseat and defecate him in this
frisbee ride and um and then wait for
the cops to come hey they call the cops
that's somebody I I wall somebody not
somebody I had just [ __ ] in a frisbee in
my car and I needed help Chinese right
you know I was just in China a dude I
saw a dude pick his nose and feed it to
a [ __ ] cat brah and the cat ate it
and it was like but that's China
you know China's like a thing you're
walking with your buddy he dies you
[ __ ] make a soup a couple people eat
in [ __ ] crews and nobody goes loved
and nobody knows nothing and the guys
honored to die and be part I was saying
trailer Home Week
what do you think I loved it man you
know but they're like they are a forward
moving place like you can't get
citizenship there as a you know like
nobody's coming into China like China's
doing their take they're ready to take
over the world but not in like a [ __ ]
up way like I don't think they're it
doesn't seem like the people are
thinking about in a military sense
they're just like we are Chinese
we are proud you know we just keep
moving forward you need something built
right there we'll [ __ ] build it we'll
build it a hundred and storeys high
you know it doesn't matter like will die
nine times will be reincarnate whatever
we got to do to just keep it moving
Tommy how many nights it was keep it
moving three three nights you just went
by you so it was great yeah we went over
there and they got a group over there
called cine Cinna
Senay productions or whatever promotions
do they do it's great they flew me
first-class put me up all bro
beautiful places on a real estate
through some of the moat hotels
[ __ ] place is so expensive I couldn't
sleep you know like 600 bucks I'm not
[ __ ]
and I'll stay awake and watch some money
go by you know at least enjoy to walk
around the room
this thing's $600 a [ __ ] night you
know they had like nine light switches
in there there it's like a [ __ ] I
don't know where I was it's insane you
can spend 40 minutes just [ __ ]
turning on all the lights [ __ ] crazy
it is man it gets really interesting
let's take another couple calls if you
don't mind I got a piece and we'll take
you home warm we'll get the [ __ ] Tyler
you got it let's do it
he said oh we with some good advice or
some suggestions I can give my wife for
her first psychedelic trip appreciate it
man love you guys whoa it's like I live
in an aquarium you see that [ __ ] guy
right there first thing for a
psychedelic trip is for his wife for his
wife just make it easy for her but then
[ __ ] with her once she's high yeah oh
wait I I think you told me a story about
this one time yeah when my first wife in
San Francisco in 85 we took some
Grateful Dead ass and we went to a party
I was very amazed to her you said her
stepdad was at the airport I kept
telling her don't you have to pick your
father up at the airport let's go then
she'd go what time is he coming in I
mean I had this poor girl going and
there was a poster of Bruce Lee out of
the wall that kept going to looking at
Bruce Lee going don't say that into her
dog don't say that I wouldn't look at me
like what's he saying I don't I put that
girl that's the girl that I wrote the
letter well thanks for watching that
video right there that was a beautiful
little segment I think but of course i'm
partisan to myself but you can move on
to another video right now you can check
on this video or on this video that's
two different options and you can also
subscribe to the channel check on a new
video subscribe to the channel check
subscribe now subscribe